independent journalism.
Uh, so great to talk to you, Richard.
Really appreciate you for having me.
So listen, we've been talking at the federal
level about what I've been seeing as red flags
when it comes to press freedom and this, a
lot of it has been coming from the Oval Office.
It includes everything from of making it easier
to sue media outlets, journalism licenses,
a refusal of interview or even spots in the
press room at the White House based on the
sort of a perceived a friendliness to the
administration.
But it's not just at the federal level that
there are things happening when it comes to
press freedom.
A lot of stuff, as in many other areas seems
to be happening at the state level.
Is that right?
I would argue that that's probably true too,
although there's probably less chance for
traction at the state level.
Um, although you can somebody throw up a lot
of impediments.
Let's talk a, or, yeah, well, I was going
to say the ethics in Journalism Act specifically
in Georgia is something that many people probably
have not heard of, but which, which would
have a significant impact on, on journalists
work.
Well, this was a bill dropped right at the
end of the legislative session.
It became public on the 2nd of April, which
was the last day, and it was filed on the
first night.
I thought it was an April fools joke initially,
but what it proposed was a journalism oversight
board, a board, um, appointed initially by
the Chancellor of the University of Georgia,
the board to be based at the very prestigious
Grady College of journalism at a Uga, uh,
to be made up of three editors, three news
producers to web, uh, journalists and one
retired journalism professor.
And the bill's suggests that the, uh, folks,
they're, the nine folks would create a candidate
of standards for journalism, um, and, uh,
credit journalists within the state and in
forced the professional standards, uh, for
journalism in the state.
Um, the bill would also require that all outtakes
from interviews such as this one, um, would
have to be provided to the interviewee within
three days of a request.
So, um, uh, outtakes, interview notes, all
photographs.
It's sort of an harassment measure against
existing journalism.
And, and in a not so subtle dig at journalists,
the bill would require that the journalists
turn over the outtakes and photographs within
three days, which is precisely the same period
that government in Georgia has to respond
to the open records act.
Um, there's no way, thankfully, that this
bill will pass.
At least I don't think it can pass.
And even if it did pass, um, the governor
of Georgia has said that he won't sign it
and I doubt there would be enough votes to,
uh, sustain it.
But it does present a really interesting insight
into what I describe as the Zeit geist now
in the country.
Now, this bill was proposed by six really
well educated people who are respected in
the legislature.
That's a former missionary, uh, who's also
works as a contractor.
There's a pharmacist, there's a doctor, a
lawyer, a retired county agent who's chair
of the education committee, and there's a
real estate development developer behind this.
They're all Republican.
Uh, there as I said, well thought of, they
come from predominantly rural areas and 10
years ago they would have been the laughing
stock for pushing a bill like this.
Now, I think the tone has changed so much
such that there's such, um, on the republican
side, such disdain for mainstream media, uh,
that they have a pass to do it.
And probably when they went back to their
districts, they got slapped on the backs and
Atta Boys.
Um, and that, that is a really disturbing
trend.
If you, if you look at the latest Edelman
Press Trust survey that came out in January,
it's a global survey with an amazing 0.6 margin
of error.
And in the US, um, 69% of Democrats said to
trust the media, but only 23% of Republicans.
Now that is a startling disconnect.
And that's the thing that scares me the most
here and really is why bills like this can
come up and get traction.
Yeah.
I mean there's this, earlier in the program
we talked about this in regard to the debate
that is going on as to whether children who
are being kept in what are effectively large
cages at the border deserve soap and bedding,
where there is a creeping normalization.
If 20 years ago you'd try to jump right to
that part of the debate.
You get no traction whatsoever.
But over time as the sort of Overton window
is pushed a little more and more in a particular
direction, then all of a sudden it seems at
least in some circles reasonable to debate
something like the accreditation of journalists.
Well, I think, um, this is not just a US issue.
Uh, I do a lot of work in eastern Europe,
uh, helping news organizations there, deal
with, uh, threats against their operations.
And particularly in Poland.
Uh, you see, uh, efforts there to control
the press.
And there it started with adjustments into
the constitution of the chords and who could
be a judge.
And how long one could stay or judge.
So existing judges, you had lots of experiences
were removed and then the judges who were
put in were much more hostile to a free press.
And they're the independent journalists, um,
are under assault, um, for their own issue
because some of them are American homes, some
of them are, have German partial German ownership.
And so the attacks come as a sort of a licensing
component, but it is all about, um, the threat
to the government that independent journalism
presents.
And when the, uh, government in question is
hanging on by a thread, as is the case in
Poland, they have a very narrow majority.
Uh, so the efforts to constrain the press
become more vigorous.
Now, I don't want to draw too many comparisons
to Georgia, but Georgia for the first time
is a state in play.
And I suspect that also comes as part of it.
Here you have folks who are really wanting
to pump up their base and wanting to get folks
really enthusiastic and out of the Poles.
And the, uh, media frankly is, uh, the boogeyman
for a lot of Republicans.
Uh, and it's easy to charge people up and,
and get people fired up by attacking a free
and independent press.
Yeah.
It's been incredibly successful to use this
a fake news term to basically become a catchall
for anything that contradicts the preexisting
narrative that may exist in some political
circles or that is critical of the current
administration.
And what's most disturbing to me is not that
this is something that the current administration
has attempted, but the success that has come
with it.
I mean, you know, the, the number of tweets
and youtube comments that I get daily saying
that my program is fake news is probably not
altogether surprising because whatever is
kind of in, in the, the insult of the day
I am the recipient of.
But the serious way in which as you point
out, it has affected particularly Republican
voters into believing that at some fundamental
level, basic news reporting cannot be trusted.
That partisan divide is what shows me how
effective it's been.
Well, I think there's another thing that journalists
like us, how to look at each other and in
the face and say we have allowed ourselves
to become too siloed.
Um, and, uh, part of the breakdown in trust
is that we have not necessarily have been
as transparent as we should be about our processes.
Uh, there's a
in what, in what sense do you mean?
Well, I think the, the public often look at
institute large journalism institutions and
they don't know how the magic happens.
They don't know the amount of work that goes
into reporting out a new story, how, how many
clothes got made, how many, uh, documents
were examined, how many foyer requests were
made, how many efforts were made to get somebody
who didn't speak to speak.
And we're not transparent enough, uh, about
that process.
There's a terrific initiative coming out to
the University of Georgia and pointer, uh,
the trusting news initiative where they're
actively working to coach news organizations
to push openness and transparency even goes
so far in some newsrooms to open up their
editorial meetings, two Facebook lives so
people can see how those editorial discussions
go.
How is the newspaper going to be stacked tomorrow?
What's going to be the lead story?
What stories are they're choosing and why
are they choosing those stories?
Um, at, at CNN when I was there, there was
a lot of action on our part towards explaining
why we did stories and how we did them and
what the process was for reporting out those
stories.
Those are all the kinds of things that help
build trust.
But as I say earlier, uh, that it's one step.
It's not a, the total solution.
We've, we've got to figure out other ways
of winning back that trust.
I agree 100%.
I think the other side of this, and I'd be
curious to hear your thought about it in the
limited time we have is the lack of media
literacy that we increasingly have in this
country.
I, uh, recently adjunct taught a course on
critical thinking and new media at Boston
College.
And a huge component of it was just explaining
to students what the differences are between
something like fake news and something like
simply that there is editorial bias in a story
and being able to distinguish between news
and opinion journalism, understanding that
anonymous source doesn't necessarily mean
anonymous to the journalist, but it is a,
a sources identity that may be kept private
from the public perspective.
All of these basic things to me seem to be
completely missing from education right now.
I completely agree with that.
Um, I uh, teach, uh, the University of North
Carolina, uh, each year and, uh, there's an
intro course that is big survey course taught
by the Dean that I help, uh, with.
And those kids are everything from premeds
to future journalism major to chemistry majors.
You have to feel fulfilled some, uh, preliminary
requirements and, uh, they're very startled
to hear that.
What journalists actually do know the names
of, of sources.
Um, uh, precisely at the point.
But also, you know, we as journalists need
to be much more careful about how we identify.
Our guest is the person who's on the air,
a reporter delivering a report.
Yes.
Or like me, uh, somebody who's giving their
opinion on, on, on journalism based on years
of experience.
So I'm, I'm certainly, uh, an an opinion person.
I'm not a reporter, although I played that
role in my career.
So identifying, uh, who we have on the air,
who the people are in the stories providing
their expertise is absolutely critical.
Yes.
Well, on that note, Richard Griffiths is president
of the Georgia First Amendment Foundation
and he has been here giving us his opinion
on the basis that he has informed that opinion,
uh, personally and not here as a reporter.
Richard, really appreciate your time today
on this really important issue.
Thank you for having me on